all right i want to play this for you
britney spears is um
freed from her conservatorship and
that's you know that happened about a
month ago after this long public
campaign to free her from a
conservatorship
lots of people joined and there were
rallies and there were you know
activists they wanted it's not fair that
she's under conservatorship and this was
something that that somehow uh crossed
both ideological
lines and
people on the left and right they were
together in this thing so we got a free
britney spears
now
one thing that i know general principle
here is that um
you know
if you hear the left calling for
something then you know it's almost
certainly wrong
but then when the other side agrees
most of the time you know that it must
really be wrong
and that i think is the case here so
britney spears was free from her
conservatorship
and she spent the last month i guess
just posting naked uh videos on
instagram and kind of rambling
incoherently
clearly demonstrating that she's a very
mentally disturbed person or her sister
jamie lynn spears has been talking about
her own experiences she wrote a book
apparently
uh trying to capitalize on all of this
but she did an interview a couple days
ago where she recounted just one of the
disturbing episodes that she recalls
from when she was a kid with britney
spears and
uh here she describes one let's listen
to that
you describe an incident where
britney takes a knife
it says she's scared and locks you and
herself into a room
why did you want to include that
in the book
because first off i think that
experiencing my own panic attacks and
how sometimes we can
um
feel in those moments
is important but also it's important to
remember that
i was a kid
in that moment i was scared that was an
experience i had
that's just one story locked in a room
with this raving lunatic with a knife i
mean who knows if she was apparently
just paranoid and psychotic and
hallucinating
and this was my point all along with the
with the britney spears conservatorship
and i you know i said this so people
were upset at me because like i said
on on the right this this became a a
cause as well a banner that they were
marching under they got a free britney
spears mercantile my point all along was
what what are you people basing this on
what are you talking about you say well
she knows you should not be on a
conservative ship how do you know that
well you don't know her you have no idea
what's going on behind the scenes
like there are a lot of famous
uh pop stars and celebrities out there
and
most of them are not under conservative
ships it's not like this is some sort of
far-reaching conspiracy
where it was like
of course this was framed in like a
patriarchal way is this because she's a
woman and well there's a lot of female
pop stars out there that are not on
conservatorships
this one is
and maybe it's wrong maybe it's unjust
but the most probably logical assumption
is that there's a reason
why she's been singled out then when you
consider that she lost custody of her
kids
which is almost impossible for a woman
to achieve especially in california
that tells you that something is very
very wrong and she was judged uh you
know a danger to her own children
and all these people
based on nothing
they saw a documentary on netflix or hbo
or whatever it was
and decided based on that that we got to
release her from a conservatorship
for all you people know
she is a
clear and present danger to herself and
others for all you know
and you saw a documentary
he saw a 90-minute propaganda film and
just decided
you didn't need to know anything about
her psychological profile you didn't
know anything about what's going on
behind the scenes
in her own life you have no idea but
let's free her
and now she's free and you know what
my prediction
and i hope i'm wrong about this but like
something she she's going to hurt
herself or she and she or someone else
or both
okay i i i will be surprised that
britney spears is still with us in five
years
so congratulations on your victory there
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated